chiche on en vient à cette nouvelle
affaire dans le cyclisme cette fois il
n'est pas question de dopage
ou alors de dopage mécanique des vélos
seraient équipés de moteurs électriques
très léger très discret très silencieux
un coureur en particulier à éveiller les
soupçons
explication aaron tanzi thierry breton
demandera ensuite son sentiment à
laurent jalabert encore devant nous a
dit ah j'avais un petit problème
mécanique finalement j'ai changé surpris
moi je comprend une seconde
déjà lors de paris roubaix le vélo de
fabian cancellara était une énigme le
vainqueur de la classique d'une heure et
du tour des flandres
aurait-il utiliser une bicyclette muni
d'un moteur électrique
l'objet du délit serait une machine de
10 kg de ce type doté d'un moteur à
batterie logée dans le cadre avec sous
le guidon un bouton permettant
d'actionner le mécanisme
moi je suis très surpris que certains
imaginent et ça mais aujourd'hui le fait
que ça existe il faut le prendre au
sérieux parce que c'est un apport c'est
un dopage mécanique et qu'un apport
énorme
vous imaginez tout ce que ça peut
engendrer un rendement supérieur et
c'est quand tu leur attention générales
d'accès et cette accélération elle aussi
pose bien des questions propulser le
tout d'un coup à plus de 50 km heure
sans forcer apparemment le 6 matière son
effort et au ralenti avec sa main droite
il semble bien appuyé sur un bouton
est ce un démarreur subtilement placé
sous le guidon pour des flandres même
geste de la main même accélération
fulgurante
aujourd'hui face aux accusations le
suisse dément c'est tellement fou que je
n'ai pas de mots je n'ai jamais eu de
batteries sur mon vélo c'est une
histoire triste et vraiment scandaleuse
la fédération internationale vient de
déclarer qu'il n'y aura aucune enquête
ouverte à l'encontre de cancellara
mais elle réfléchit à une parade tous
les vélos du tour de france seront
minutieusement contrôlés